turn yourself
okay why don't we open up the
subcommittee of the commerce committee
and first one uh is senate bill 202
prohibiting the sale of cosmetic
products tested on animals
uh so who do we have here for
subcommittee
this was business business business news
okay weston
hunt osborne ham
johnson abel weston fargo
six seven
hebert and mcaleer
one two three four we're just reading
off the list okay so you had you had
able
[Music]
in
in business
okay
you are
okay right yeah i got the hand johnson
johnson able western fargo herbert and
max beer it just seems like a
a lot of people
okay that's nine
and and it's five and four
one two three four
it looks like three four one two three i
don't know why these were on here well
there's a there's too many people here
yeah
um
which i asked yeah so yeah so we he has
on his separate piece of paper
it was able weston and fargo and didn't
have her britain immaculate
so you always thought there were five on
there
so that means i have to have six
okay so i got
osbourne yeah
yeah sarah him
okay
johnson we need two more no let's let's
not do that again
okay i got
like greasy two three four
five and then and then uh
then i get terry
oh
i don't the four those extra two i
thought were supposed to replace two
people over here the democrats on the
other side that's what i thought
that that herbert and macular were added
and abel and i thought abel and
weston
i know but i'm just saying that's what i
i thought when we had those two names on
the side there
but i am i'm more than willing to
okay
so um
okay okay so here's my list for today
which i believe i have the power to do
this
okay hunt batusik osborne ham greason
johnson and terry
hunt batusik osborne ham greason johnson
and terry
on
abel herbert fargo weston and mcaleer
okay
seven to five
so we have a amendment here
this is 1656 h
how many people how many people need a
copy of it
who needs a copy
give me john give me another
one my god
1656 is correct
okay
so uh kurt
do you mind coming up and
so you've seen this amendment correct
i saw the eu sent it to me on friday in
an email if it's the same great i'm just
receiving it officially now okay but i'm
sure your printer printed out
essentially it takes the word cosmetics
out and it
provides the state of new hampshire with
the ability to ban all
products tested on animals
for sale is that correct that is correct
all products right
so you have been given an opportunity to
see this and you have uh done your best
to find out where i might have dropped
the ball i provided everyone with our
synopsis of of the amendment okay on
paper um
i hope you can read it
digest it uh before you discuss it and
vote on it
mr chair
yes
could we ask mr ehrenberg to um go over
what he's sent out given to us
i'll just read it
dear representatives
uh the proposed amendments to sb202
appears to have severe unintended
consequences for many essential products
unfortunately and we would love to see
uh
animal testing
stopped
as much as possible uh i would just say
that
to state that as a
before we begin uh unfortunately there
are many types of products that require
animal testing that are not adequately
addressed in this language such as
pharmaceutical products if any of you
took a
pharmaceutical product this morning such
as i did myself or blood pressure
that would not be allowed because that's
tested on animals probably and that
wouldn't be allowed to be sold in new
hampshire under this amendment
over-the-counter drugs vaccines food
additives industrial chemicals just to
name some
and i've just spelled out some of the
four areas where they would be
prohibited
which probably are essential to most of
our lives today
and i
there's a link in the actual email which
i did provide to
perhaps not all of you
but to the chairman
early on he had this
ranking member
bartlett also had this early on in
discussions of this amendment when it
was first brought up last week
um so the chairman you have had access
to this for at least a week yep um so
if you if you are able to look into
these links there are food and drug
administration regulations all kinds of
federal
laws and regulations that would
supersede anything that this uh
this legislature could could do on its
own um this this bill as it stands and
was passed unanimously by the senate
um
has uh well thought out carved out
exemptions it has passed eight states it
is a fed it is a mirrors a federal law
that is
unfortunately stuck in congress as many
bills good bills are
which is why the industry
the
personal care products association has
endorsed this legislation
um
along with
uh the federal legislation
you're repeating what you've said in
testimony okay i'm sorry yeah that's
fine okay so the question i have for you
is um there are two sections but i'll
start with the one that seems most
obvious to me
is uh roman e
uh under 359 t2
t and we got it right t t1
uh
you wanna see this where is
i
oh so three
pharmaceutical or medical product
so that is not does not take care of
pharmaceuticals medical devices vaccines
i'm not i'm i mean i am not familiar
enough with the federal law to know or
the exact
uh you know the fact that this may or
may not pass muster in the courts et
cetera
i would say that it certainly isn't
sufficient
um and and that's my opinion uh
and i would say it doesn't cover a
plethora of other products
what what part of pharmaceutical or
medical product does not include
pharmacies and other
perhaps over the counter drugs medical
device what where what part do those two
perhaps perhaps it works for you it
doesn't work for me got it okay so i
won't even bother pointing out the other
one in roman numeral two
which says uh anytime it poses a human
okay so this is just uh we can agree to
disagree
and but that i did ask you on you know
when i sent you a copy of this to tell
me if there was anything specifically in
statute that you thought i needed to add
to ensure this and and the best you can
say is
that you think there's unintended
consequences but if you asked me where
in the federal law were there conflicts
yeah where i provided that to you but
you know i'm i think i respond to you
perfect as quickly as possible any time
i'm not uh it's fine that's great and i
i you know i appreciate my i know that
this is not uh customary for you to call
on me and i appreciate the time today
good thanks all right
any questions uh for him yep
representative van halen
thank you mr chair thank you mr
ehrenberg am i correct correctly
pronouncing your name erin berg thank
you um
as i recall when i was reviewing this
the amendment pretty well parallels the
original bill is that
pretty much the case i mean it looks as
though it takes out i mean i didn't
write it but it takes out
the word cosmetic space right but it
does pretty well parallel are you
familiar with any states that are
currently
following what the amendment indicates
about products tested on animals
globally or would we be the first
outlier to do this type of thing
what is in the original bill no i
understand the original bill the
original bill
is the same as other
but the amendment are you aware of any
states that are following so that not
this would be the first i am not aware
of
whether it is being used or whether it
would be the first i i can't tell you
either one
um so may i just ask you about your
opinion of the breadth of this is this
too broad in your opinion to be viable
for new hampshire the so cosmetics is an
area that we are able to actually
get this done and
test products without animals suffering
this bill does that this bill is a great
step forward for the animals
that are now suffering daily
tests being tested
we've been very careful to make sure
that there are the right exemptions that
all of the areas that people
absolutely need the products that stood
on animals
will be able to use those products and
that there are no
retailer in the state
would be held responsible if the
manufacturer of the products are
responsible
and that no data that is collected
anywhere could be used
uh
to to provide for a product
being included
in
as a as data that was tested on animals
could not be included i hope that was
clear probably wasn't um
thanks for the question
representative johnson second by
representative patusek moves ought to
pass on amendment number 1656
is there any discussion on the motion
okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one
two
are you you're not you're not not yet
not yet
one two three four five six seven
and those opposed
one two three four five
okay
yeah okay
so then
uh
yes
i take each subcommittee in if it if
it's related to that at uh en entity i
don't you know just that one seemed to
have
so more democrats than you can shake a
stick at so
i
decided to
i decided to beef it up
um no it's not a problem i was trying to
be funny but
um
okay
all right uh so the motion uh moved uh
representative johnson
second by representative patusek
uh moves uh ought to pass as amended
okay motion clear
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one two three four five six seven
those opposed
one two three four five
okay
why did i think there was six hands up
who
was voting wasn't supposed to vote
so you really don't want to take care of
puppies do you okay
all right i'm i'm sorry i i my personal
opinion is i don't know how anybody
could be opposed to this amendment if
you really really care
about animals
why would you
why would you pick one industry oh
because cosmetics are an unnecessary
product because it's not going to apply
why why would it who's going to
why would anybody vote against this
i'm not killing the bill i don't think
we're
okay
that's that's your opinion that skill
bill so i guess so you're saying the
senate that is going to kill this bill
you could say the governor is going to
veto it if we pass it this way
who says it's not workable the only
person says is curtin says his opinion
okay
we don't have to discuss this anymore
we'll take it up when the executive
session
okay
all right next up is
okay uh 355 we did already take action
on this and had uh interim study so um
at this point i think we'll just leave
it leave it at that
excuse me mr chair yes is there some
reason why we had it on today's agenda
um i did put it on the agenda because i
was forcing this bill to be taken up
today rather than last week
and um i i just out of habit thought if
any bill that we're taking up i just was
in case there was something comes up we
could we would have it okay so we have
venture and study five four out of
subcommittee is that correct correct
okay
all right uh
senate bill 340. um senate bill 340 is
still not ready
um as you remember there was some
conversation uh i think the kim
subcommittee already moved um
it had moved uh
in expedient as i believe is it
and um so that will be the pending
motion going forward
and hopefully my my
my new amendment will be ready by the
time we take it up otherwise i might be
tempted to bring my amendment onto the
house floor
but at this point um that there
no need to subcommittee at it
i guess i could pre uh just tell
everybody where i'm at and what i've
been doing um so everybody understands
uh where where what you had when i sent
it to you last night
um and that is uh this this bill
i guess i would first by begin to tell
everybody
forget about who
requested the bill
all right you could say
senator daniels brought this bill in for
a constituent
but
i would have to say this every time we
have changed our liquor laws and it goes
i can think back when
um
uh
but we had
from lee the for the first person who
wanted to had distilled vodka john stark
vodka and he just wanted to be able to
sell it flag hill he just wanted to sell
it in his facility
because that was illegal that the only
place you could get distilled alcohol
was at the new hampshire liquor store so
theoretically he was sending people
to the liquor store he was the only
person who requested that bill
there was nobody else who came in for
that bill as far as i know he might have
been the only distiller in the state
at the time
so yes representative
thank you mr chair i'll say we did get
this some email from um
aiden moore regarding the number of
licenses that have the direct to
consumer permit
and the numbers um
show that only one brewing company has
been taking advantage of this permit
now
would you confirm with me that right now
there's supposed to be a
a limit of 27 gallons
per
individual
per individual
delivery for individual delivery that
and that is what he pointed out was um
that the
the downside of having that
per individual per year i've been put
yeah the 20 was 27
was it 27 ounces gallons gallons right
so that was a per year delivery
so
and was was lifted when i did the direct
shipping law and when i did the direct
shipping law i was assuming
a case of beer a month
so that's where that cut that number
came from okay now the numbers that um
mr moore prevent provided to us show
that there were 3 509
16 ounce deliveries right we don't know
how many individuals because the person
that's delivering them has not been
keeping records is that correct no
that's not what happened the the liquor
commission didn't say to
that when they had that report issued
they never said oh by the way
did uh how many you know give us a
breakdown of all the people
and tell me how much you delivered to
each one of those people
now i would bet you
you probably think that that maybe is a
little more tuned in from too much
information to be put on a piece of
paper
that would you want a the beverage
manufacturer
stating in writing on a piece of paper
distributed to all house reps or all
house committee anyway it came to me and
i distributed to you but that list
everybody's listing their names and how
much beer they bought this year
no we weren't going to do that i don't
think that's what i was asking i think i
was asking um about the 27 gallons they
were complying
with the law as it stood now uh
my understanding was that that that they
there was compliance yes
how did we know that they were
complaining okay
okay again because now we have a bill
asking to increase it to 50 gallons and
what you're saying is that
there's an amendment coming that would
not have any limit to it correct
so the 27's out the window okay the 50
gallons and the bill would be out the
window and any limit would be it so they
can deliver as much beer as they want to
any individual
right so now i'll get into my second
part of my story
okay my second part of my story is
that if you were to come into a rest a a
go to a
nano brewer in this case or a brewer and
you would go there
every day
and buy a four
pack you would probably exceed that 27
gallons
the point i was trying to make with this
new amendment is
that no
beverage manufacturer winery distillery
anyone who produces alcohol except
rectifiers
anyone who produces alcohol should be
allowed to do the exact same thing to
give the person whatever they order
whatever they want to buy
as long as they have that face-to-face
contact
they know the person
hasn't over consumed
they've got a check on the driver's
license
and as a bonus
they cannot deliver
to college campuses
okay so what i was trying to do is take
what we had already done with the
restaurants
so if you're going to have any problems
with this you have to go look at the
restaurant statute and see that we had
already passed all that
and say is that
it i have to admit never crossed my mind
that any
alcohol producer would think it's a good
idea to deliver to end users
it seemed very expensive
cost prohibitive
and a pain in the neck
but
if the fact that we have one
and we know that we have
other deliveries that are going on
in terms of uh we have the the
restaurant statute
that are delivering alcohol
why not just say
once and for all pass one bill i mean
that's true we could just kill this
thing and i'll bri i'll introduce this
build next year
but if we already are so close to
knowing exactly where we want to be
why wouldn't it be worth it to try to do
it but if you want to vote against this
now that's fine and i won't hold it
against you when you vote for it again
next year when you see the logic of the
idea that we should have a level playing
field among all alcohol producers
that simply says if you want to deliver
you've got to use the same requirements
that the restaurants have so this is now
going to open up the floodgates so i i
would guarantee you that won't open
floodgates
beer wine distilled spirits anything
with no limits
should be able to be delivered to
somebody's home or place of business is
that correct correct
so why do we have liquor stores
um
that's the old model and you know let me
put it this way to say is that we would
only pass that if we got rid of liquor
stores no we we're just saying is why
not if we're if we're allowing other
people to deliver
why shouldn't we allow the manufacturer
to deliver what what's wrong now i i
guess if i was connie
i would say well this is trampling the
three-tier model
right
so she's against brew pubs
and yeah because they're they're the
number one trampler of the three-tier
system they were they were the first
trampler see that was a stampede that
trampled it
yeah it exists that's what i'm saying
okay
okay so uh representative herbert
represent representative herbert uh just
a couple questions um
is
the tax
being collected yes
there okay so what we turned out not
okay no
this is actually an interesting answer
evidently when we passed the direct
to
consumer statute
last year right we did not include the
eight percent tax
so yes
all product will still have to pay
whatever their manufacturing tax whether
it's 30 cents a gallon for beer or the
um whatever the tax rate is
for wine and distill is this person
i mean are the other retailers that are
uh selling
and delivering to places are they
audited i mean we do at this point are
we just taking their word for it at this
point okay
we don't uh it's based on that report we
saw that there was nobody else was
taking advantage of the direct to
consumer statute other than abel
ebenezer right and then anyway he paid a
tax of like three hundred and eleven
dollars
and that tax just so you remember if you
did the math yep
was 30 cents a gallon
i didn't do the math the second question
my understanding the bill that you're
citing that we already passed in regards
to
delivery the restaurants can deliver
you know alcohol
without really
knowing who's actually drinking the
alcohol
that was passed in uh
in extremis in other words we were in a
pandemic
uh the restaurants were struggling
mightily
to survive
well so we'd know the federal government
no no that originally was done by the
governor's order
so the silver lining of having that
originally done by a gold the governor's
order
was that liquor enforcement actually put
in the w-2 piece and the no college
delivery
that was actually put in under the
governor's order when the governor's
order expired there was a period of time
where we had nothing and yes we then
passed the we basically said that was
successful it was a good business model
some restaurants continue to want to do
it
and so we then passed the restaurant
piece outside of covington well my a b
question uh you know
the fact of the matter is
it was
uh the reason i believe the public did
not get up in arms because you were we
were now delivering alcohol to a home
and with no
uh
with nobody knowing exactly who's going
to be drinking the alcohol
and then
but there was a pandemic so there was we
did what we could to try and help uh the
restaurant businesses
uh who were struggling
the pandemic's over
right and that's why we passed the
direct-to-consumer statutes now
has gone all the way into the tent and
it's competing against a public system
and
you know my view in terms of
you know financializing public systems
um so i'm i do have a problem i i still
have the problem there's no checking on
who's drinking it
and i and i'm i'm skeptical about
uh some people's uh views on whether or
not they need to pay taxes
are quite extreme and
and and and the fact of the matter is
the pandemic is over got it the rest
okay we got we got that part okay
so
okay we don't need to get this floor we
got it represented below
is it possible to hear from the liquid
commission today
it can be we can have him
uh i'll take some other questions and
then i'll have them come up and speak
okay thanks uh representative fargo was
the next one to have her hand up
okay
yep
and over here i saw some more hands
uh manhattan
thank you mr chair um one thing i'd like
to clarify in your email that i believe
came out last night um you referenced
179 colon 15 roman 3 and and you said
deleting everything after sealed
containers i just would like to clarify
that you're only talking about deleting
a portion of a sentence and not the
whole rest of it correct so yeah and i
would have to say that the new amendment
is it turns out that that that amendment
had the word restaurant in it more than
i
was paying attention so uh the next
amendment that i hope to have will
actually
delete the as provided by rsa 179-15
but will pick up in 179-115
three paragraphs that are in that
statute which are the ones that i'm
referring to which is the uh
the um
[Music]
a uh you know having to uh be a w-2
and that you can't deliver to colleges
okay and may i just clarify an earlier
point that you made um my belief in
looking at the three-tier system i'm not
saying it's the bl and end all of
anything but i think it should be
examined um
that doesn't mean i'm against any
industry they've taken advantage of the
loopholes the mother may eyes that we've
done and so um i am i realize the income
that we bring but i also realize that uh
it is incumbent upon us sitting here
today to make sure that any legislation
that we pass going forward regardless of
emergency action is one of safety and
you you've compared buying a four pack
on
on-site in person to having a delivery
to the home and you mentioned something
about we know that
the owner of that liquor now is not
over-concerned and there are issues that
are they're very different um if i'm on
site with a valid id and you can tell
that i
had too much of a dream as opposed to
falling over then chances are good i
have not uh over consumed but leaving it
at someone's door i think no leaving at
the door well no leaving another door no
i i miss hope
i am well aware of what it says in 179
colon 15 and
i misspoke on that but nonetheless i
think it's a different thing to go back
to what chris herbert was saying um to
to have someone you know you close the
door and the liquor is on the other side
of that door i know that there are
safeguards that have been put in but i
don't think they're adequate anymore i
think we put them through for the
pandemic for the emergency action and
that was all well and good for for that
time but i think we now have the
opportunity to look at this more fully
and to make it better and more safe uh
and i will say that as we well i'm
actually on the liquor committee i'm
free to say that thank you very much
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair
seems to me with all of these changes um
with all of the discussion that to do
this
to pass
to even consider passing this bill
without a public hearing
would be um not a good idea i think that
there are enough stakeholders that would
need to be involved
um to
participate in the in the discussion
would be really necessary
so you're arguing this is a non-jermaine
here uh amendment
my argument is that we have not had a
public hearing on it and i don't think
well this is a publicly
no this is a subcommittee
the subcommittee publication public okay
so you want a public meeting
on the amendment so you are claiming
this is a non-germain amendment
so you would like me to hold a
non-germain hearing
i would like to have a public hearing on
the amendment
want to do that next wednesday we can do
that
but i i i believe we have session on
wednesday i thought session was thursday
but thursday we have wednesday and
thursday so uh
would you like to do it on tuesday
i think that we need to have a public
hearing on this amendment i will check
to see what the clerk's office is that
if we can have another public hearing
okay
everybody all set
oh i'm sorry yes representative greeson
thank you mr chair
when uh when
somebody stops by the store and picks up
a case of beer or whatever it is that
they purchase and they go home who
drinks it
is this a rhetorical question yeah it's
it's the argument that's being okay i
don't understand but that's the return
once it is once it is delivered who's
consuming it well once it's purchased at
the store who's consuming it okay
anyway uh
mark
danielle you guys want to come up and
tell us what you think
out of the system
and giving it to a private private
business
good morning mr chairman
committee members uh for the record my
name is mark armagenian uh as most of
you know uh the chief and director of
liquor enforcement and with me today is
danielle elston our deputy chief and
deputy director
do you want to have the question posed
to you so you know what she's what
they're asking for
absolutely if
if that's okay yeah that's my preference
here yeah you're not you're not
testifying answering questions okay yes
representative van hounten
thank you and it's good to see you thank
you for being here um i think my primary
issue
is that
there has to be a safeguard has to be
safety here for all involved i realize
some things are not going to be 100 all
or none but do you feel that this
amendment and probably that's not an
appropriate question for you but does
this amendment
present any loopholes
for public safety particularly things
like underage drinking things of that
sort
thank you for your question uh
representative um
so i think i
as you know
are i hope by now after five years uh
most of you know that
um
i have three
spokes my wheel that i'm very concerned
about
always
industry safety community safety and
the restricted age
access
um that vulnerable age group is
something that i pay a lot of attention
to and that's why i appreciate your
question
more so than the rest of the questions
um
what ends up happening here is is quite
frankly and and
uh it was i i think
brought up a little earlier
um
we're looking at the access as the
access point and the access point is
point of purchase
so
uh our major concern is that the person
that is actually taking control of this
alcohol is of legal age
and and quite frankly a signing
with the delivery service signing for
that alcohol
um and they
uh fall into the categories of no
outward signs of intoxication
and and
is a person that is able to because of
the age restriction or non-age
restriction able to take custody of that
alcohol
may follow up
thank you
to address my question a little bit more
fully
do you see any further loopholes that
are created
by this amendment again and i do
recognize that this is not going to be
perfect as as the representative
mentioned before i can buy alcohol and
then have
17 17 year olds in my home
which of course is another law and
another issue but do you see that this
is any
other safety ramifications here that
have not been addressed or that we
perhaps should look at rather than
going forward with
i would
reserve the
the issue of there could be a
scenario out there i will just share a
little bit with you when we got um
advised of what was going on with this
amendment we went scenario based on it
and that we do that quite frequently we
go scenario base and and we tried to
beat this up into the late
i will say the late hours of the night
um we were pushing actually this morning
i'm trying to figure out what
scenario would actually create
a a breach in the system
of of ajax or restricted age access and
we didn't come up with one that's not to
say one isn't there
but
in in the two to three people that we
had together uh covering field
operations
uh myself the deputy uh in our
administration our licensing side of the
house um we we did not come up with a
scenario that would breach
uh that other than an unresponsible
adult
that
disseminates
double disseminates if that's a term
gives the alcohol to which is a totally
different issue which i have issue of
and i've spoken publicly about before
also and that's
parents or or adults of legal age giving
alcohol to minors
i think that
and i respect what you said that you
didn't find that that loophole that may
may well be there and i would just like
to comment on that and and thank you for
your your statement um it is probably
best in our best interest for something
that's coming up now and we haven't even
seen the amendment to look for that
loophole to look uh to study to have
public testimony to do our due diligence
here because um i appreciate that you
spent half your night doing this for us
but you you yourself say that there may
well be a loophole an unintended
loophole and um i i i'm on the liquor
subcommittee and have been on the liquor
subcommittee not because i'm an expert
on any of this but because my concerns
are typically things like um underage
drinking
vaping things of that sort and i'm
coming at it from that perspective and
i'm
fairly sure now from your comment that
we need to do a little bit more to add
to the due diligence that you've already
done in order to come to the table with
something that would be workable and
doable for our constituents for people
who
are looking to us to bring some wisdom
to the table thank you
uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
so i guess one of my questions would
have to be
addressing what you were saying about um
somebody buying for underage
my feeling is it's not uncommon
for someone of age to purchase liquor
beer
wine
for somebody under age happens all the
time
this certainly would make it easier
wouldn't you agree
um thank you for your question uh
representative and and
i
i feel like i'm at the old garden with
obstructed view um
i
i i would say that i don't
this is a problem
i we we have talked about it
um and and it's always been a concern of
mine i don't know if it creates any more
than the rest of the system
um
it creates
uh the same hurdles that we would have
in a combination a grocery store
as we would have in takeout service as
we would have
and quite possibly
i hope this doesn't happen and we
haven't seen it because we are pretty
strict with our our state-owned stores
but it could happen in our state-owned
stores also
once once the consumer gets custody of
of that that consumable product
it uh
we hope that they use their best
discretion
and in making those good choices
and being responsible um that's why we
have laws in this state that's why we
rely on all of you
graciously to to create them
um so i i don't i don't think my my
humble opinion i don't think it creates
more but it it creates it the the same
concerns are there as the rest of the
industry
masculine yes sir
thank you
so
in the example of the liquor store
you're dealing with a liquor employee
who won his jobs on the line if he
knows that or the possibility seems to
exist that this liquor is going to be
just
given to somebody under age and they are
trained
um those in a grocery store again
they're trained i mean i they card me
when i
when i buy liquor because it goes
through the computer
but do you think
by lifting all limits
i mean there's not going to be any
limits to how much can be brought to a
residence
of liquor over the course of a year
neither
the delivery or the
those are accepting i mean it's pretty
much a confidential
type of transaction wouldn't you agree
um
so the limits that thank you again the
limits that are there
what this
what i see when this was um
proposed to us what i see is this
creating parody
um we're neutral on this as an agency
but
the combinations who have been able to
deliver and i call them combination
grocery store
convenience store they've been able to
deliver
gosh way before my existence here um and
and they have no limits
so
those same concerns
and for us as an enforcement group those
same concerns
are are already there with other
other groups
like i say
grocery stores whether it's hannifer
shaw's market basket they can do that
they've been able to do that
all the way back to i think the
existence of that license type the
grocery stores don't have liquor
no they wine and they have beer no and
so by you know lifting
and allowing this for
all types of alcohol um does change the
equation wouldn't you agree it it does
um because of the um the volume of
alcohol
but again the standard what we use as a
standard
is
the same standard straight across the
board so we don't look at it would be
like looking at drugs
differently like some drugs are more
acceptable than other drugs drugs that
are illegal are illegal straight across
the board and we look at the alcohol and
the youth access as the same way
whether it's liquor just because it's a
wine cooler doesn't make it more
acceptable than a bottle of vodka it
we don't look at it that way
thank you thank you
representative fargo
hi it's nice to see you again hi nice to
see you um in your estimation does this
legislation give competitive edge to a
company that has the potential to
possibly undermine the new hampshire
liquor commission um
i don't
that i don't know
uh and the only reason i say that is
we're on the enforcement side of it
and and not on the marketing side to
actually talk to the people that
my counterparts on the marketing side of
the house that actually run the stores
to see if there is a competitive edge or
not
um i look at this from an enforcement
point of view
in a regulatory point of view thank you
thank you
representative abel
yes thank you and thank you for uh
answering some difficult questions um
my question goes back to
to
representative herbert's comment earlier
um
would this pose any new problems
for for
auditing
uh or
ensuring that
that the appropriate tax
are p is paid
uh thank you and i can answer that
question for you so
the the tax that we're speaking about
for the manufacturers is paid based on
what they're manufacturing there is no
tax paid on what they're delivering so
this doesn't change the tax that's
collected or the auditing of the tax for
the manufacturing purposes
i think what the tax that everyone is
referencing is the out-of-state direct
shippers
there is a tax collected with what they
ship in that's not the case to the
in-state consumers so in terms of
auditing for tax purposes the tax the
this doesn't change what the
manufacturers report what they're
manufacturing and the taxes that they
pay on that
representative johnson
did you have a question
thank you i was trying to figure out
um
so with this i just want to make sure i
want to clarify something
so if
they are delivering directly to the
consumer
and
they pay their taxes that they have to
pay based on their deliveries and
that's not taking away from it's
actually inc could be increasing our
state sales
tax because we're getting more people
buying it directly from them and we
still have the state
doing their liquor
so we're actually increasing sales
correct
it's it's hard to say because the tax
isn't based on the delivery of the
products the tax is based on what they
manufacture
so
could it increase their manufacturing i
don't know it it's it's the potential is
there the potential the potential is
there so that we could increase our tax
revenues
because now we're not only delivering
through our state liquor stores and
such but also through our direct
manufacturing deliveries
correct this is thank you to the direct
manufacturing
okay
so i just had a conversation with the
house clerk and uh he agrees uh uh with
the um the issue of this being a
non-germane amendment
and uh unfortunately we're out of time
to have a non-germane hearing
so uh at this point uh
the amendment is
withdrawn well actually we didn't
actually put a motion forward um but i
will all i can say is um
stay tuned
the bill might show up somewhere else
i can't we can't pass this bill at this
time we can't it this cannot take it
effect so at this point the pending
motion is uh
is uh
itl
um so what happens i would like us to
reconsider that and interim study
the the bill
so that this amendment can always be
looked at in the future
so
i
okay what oh
i don't hold any secrets yes i'm going
to go over to the senate and give this
amendment to the senate
okay
this is a senate bill if gary daniels
wants it to happen
he'll find a home for it and we'll see
it
in the committee conference okay so i'm
confused we had an itl on a subcommittee
so right now the subcommittee pending
motions itl
um clearly
uh clearly i i'm not you know i'm not
happy with an itl motion because
obviously i kept working on this bill
thinking that there was a solution so at
this point i would uh like the
subcommittee to change its motion to
interim study
or we can not do that it'll just take up
interim study when we when we take it up
as a full committee okay so that's your
motion is interesting you'll be interim
study on this bill okay thanks
okay
all right
i guess we can just leave it at that we
don't you know i'm gonna
have to have the subcommittee take any
action but i do want to the key thing is
i i did want to have everybody have an
opportunity to express their concerns
and thoughts and about what this what
this bill what we're trying to do here
so at least no one can say when we get
to committee conference or this does
reappear that you can't say that you've
never heard about this before so and i'm
really confused now though
we had a subcommittee on april 14th
correct and that was itl four to one
correct okay
now you're saying
we're not having a subcommittee on this
uh i i
i we could do would you like to have a
subcommittee on it do you want to
reconsider we could either a we could re
reconsider our action
because i'm completely confused now
because you were just talking about
interim study
that i'm the senate bill 340
can't get out of th you because i would
want this amendment because this
amendment can't be attached to it
and for all kinds of purposes that
i'm i'm suggesting that we would hold on
to 340
so that if nothing ever happens to this
amendment
the rest of the session at least we have
a subcommittee so we can continue to
work on it and have a public hearing on
this amendment well i guess we won't
even need to bother with that because
it'll come up come in as a separate
bills so how does this go into the
calendar so you rather have just you
just rather kill it i just well i guess
the only reason i wouldn't want to kill
it is i wouldn't want anybody to get up
on the house floor
when the committee conference comes over
and refuses the committee conference on
the grounds that that well actually no
it's not because this language is
totally different that's the whole point
so you can never argue that 340 this is
340. no that i take it back i'm all
i was worried that that someone would
argue against if this amendment showed
up in another bill
would argue against this amendment
by saying
that we killed the bill
but we really didn't because there's
nothing in this amendment that really
actually refers to the original bill
so
right now we're at itl out of the
subcommittee which means we're going to
execute in a few minutes correct and the
recommendation out of the subcommittee
is itl at this point so that would be
the motion in the exact session that's
fine and then if that were to pass that
way
it goes on to the calendar
as itl
as far as i'm concerned send it on the
consent calendar and send it on its way
okay okay
okay guys i think yes representative
chair it appears to me there are two
ways forward with respect to interim
study and i'm wondering which one you
prefer at this point so we can move
things along yeah the first is you could
the subcommittee can reconsider its itl
and and it yes it can just know
we could we could reconsider it and then
no interim study so but i don't know if
we don't need it so
the the the subcommittee could
reconsider its itl and then vote is as a
recommendation for the exact session or
we can just kill itl when it comes
before the full committee in the exec
session and then do i s so do you have a
preference for which
course of action you wish to take
at this point uh i just assume leave it
at
it so we'll take it up in the executive
session and we'll deal with the itl and
then the is if the itl fails
itl is fine
you itl is fine you just itl is fine you
just want to keep okay it was a bad idea
to just raise the dollar and
that was a bad idea so no interim study
itl going forward okay thank you
okay representative
just have a question are we gonna caucus
before exec yes
okay
all right representative van halen at
the risk of being obtuse or more of
juice than usual you said you would take
the uh amendment over to the senate
correct did you clarify
what the process is for that and why
you're doing that uh senate has uh no
rules about non-germain amendments
but they've they're already done with
this bill right
i
the fact that the bill was sitting on
the table in the senate and they took it
off and passed it
on their last day
evidently they're not done with it
and they will probably be dancing in the
street when they see me coming
so to be continued correct
stay tuned
okay
any more discussion all right and
uh 319 we we do yeah we have pending
action on that so there's no need for
another subcommittee okay so uh
the
subcommittee session for the commerce
committee is closed bam
okay and so we'll uh take what happened
to 319
right we'll we we already know what
we're going to do with 319
right
where
we'll have a reconsideration on our
previous motion
and then we'll just take up a vote
okay i had that on the subcommittee work
session i know i told you i put
everything out of habit i just put
everything on sub command
that was just out of habit
okay
all right
everybody take their seats
okay
are we ready
everybody in i guess i should count
don't make that mistake again
okay
uh
senate bill 202 prohibiting the sale of
cosmetic products tested on animals
representative
johnson second by representative terry
moves ought to pass on the amendment
and for the record
uh the amendment will need one uh typo
call it that
uh in which uh evidently the reference
uh
in
roman numeral two b the reference to the
food and drug and cosmetic act 21 usc
section and that is supposed to be 301
okay so it's line 22 if you have a bill
have you had the amendment in front of
you with numbers on it
21 on the amendment and
page 2 page 2
line 4 on the original bill
301 it should be it says 350.
the amendment replaces the entire bill
so at this point we're only we so we
don't have to worry about the
we can say you know that somebody else
screwed up and before we got it but but
it was uh at this point this amendment
is um repens the bill by replacing all
after the enacting clause so we're
replacing everything in the original
bill
okay
all right any discussion on the motion
of
ought to pass on the amendment
yes representative abel
yes i believe that the original bill is
a much superior bill to
the amended bill and so i urge everyone
to vote against
approving the amendment
okay representative van hounten
thank you just to reiterate what i said
during the subcommittee it uh it is way
too broad a bill
it may have unattended consequences may
have loopholes that are going to be big
enough to drive a truck through and it
would quite likely make us the first
state to have this type of legislation
and i'm not sure that without further
study it would be a good
a good thing for us to be first so i
will um
um i will vote accordingly thank you
so um
myself personally i was opposed to this
bill from the get-go
because of all the exemptions
yes i think there
this is this is a convoy when when you
have a bill that's one sentence
and even in the initial sentence the
cosmetic it had but not soap it already
had an exemption already in the in the
definition and then went on and had a
second page full of exemptions
which would always caution me to want to
be in support of that bill however
that once the concept of saying is but
why don't we just
not pick on one industry
let's just say make a statement which is
what this is all it is if you ask me
make a statement that says that in new
hampshire we don't want you testing for
animals for any reason
and yes we understand that
pharmaceuticals and medical products and
governments will require companies to do
the testing but that's part of the
convoy of exemptions that are in here
representative bilo
yeah i um support i'm supporting the
original bill
because
it was proven to me that cosmetics can
be tested
on um
in in labs versus on animals so it's you
you they will be able to still
manufacture
but they won't be able to test the other
exact exemptions they need to use
animals so that's why there's an
exception
i i don't get that but it's your opinion
just to share yes representative thank
you
um
taking into consideration
the
federal exemptions as outlined at least
partially
with the distribution from mr ehrenberg
if i'm an animal
i'm not going to care whether it's
cosmetics or something else
that is causing me pain
cruelty
is cruelty
and so just to select out cosmetics and
cosmetic manufacturers
seems to me to be particularly cruel to
animals
and therefore i'm speaking i will speak
in favor of the amendment because
cruelty is cruelty and hurt is hurt
thank you
fair enough
any more discussion representative below
for a second time this bill was proposed
for the cosmetic industry
okay
having no more discussion on the motion
uh the clerk will call the role on ought
to pass on the amendment
and it's amendment number one six five
six each
so right yes correct
representative patosik yes
representative osborne
representative admin votes yes
representative sanborn
representative ham yes representative de
palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel no
representative herbert
representative van halton no
representative fargo no
representative weston no
representative bill you no
representative burroughs no
representative mclear
no
and representative hunt
yes
ten to nine
okay uh representative johnson second
representative terry moves out to pass
as a men did
any discussion on the motion
see none the clerk will call the roll
i'm sorry who were the johnson and terry
all right representative patusik yes
representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative sanborn
representative hamm
representative palmer
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no representative abel no
representative herbert
representative van houghton no
representative fargo no
representative weston no
representative bell you
no
representative burroughs no
representative mclaren no
chairman hunt yes 10 to 9.
i assume there'll be a minority report
mr chair i have i haven't polo i have a
question about the proposed amendment
there is it there there needs to be a
correction correct the number that 303
so how will that be handled
so we'll we'll make that correction and
make sure that the right amendment is
submitted with the bill
so i mean you mean
i mean in terms of um
the senate doesn't that you know they do
that all the time
but i don't normally is on policy i
would never do that um but in this case
it's pretty straightforward and the fact
that that number was a problem from day
one
um
you know
you know i i don't think that we need to
unless you don't want to send this bill
to the floor and
[Music]
i mean i i mean in terms of the
amendment we can sit we can wait till
this afternoon and do it again
i just don't think it's right okay
all right so will be a minority yes
representative bolio will do it
okay
and your motion will be
no your their motion would be odd to
pass on the original bill
okay
okay we're on to the next one
all right
senate bill 355 requiring online
marketplaces to disclose certain
information to consumers
so representative terry seconded by
representative osborne
moves
interim study
any discussion on the motion of interim
study
representative weston now i really
strongly support this bill i don't i
think the interim study will just be a
quiet death and i think we should pass
it
i sent around a new york times article
last weekend
which really outlines the problems with
amazon
that they just don't consider themselves
a seller and they get away with
having third-party
sellers that are just not reputable and
if someone tries to pursue those
third-party sellers amazon pretty much
just tells them to go pound sand so this
is not about the small marketplace the
individual marketplace this is
about amazon and i think it needs to be
controlled i think this bill should pass
so i'm going to vote against interim
study
okay representative van gaal
thank you i agree i think that
this is there's an immediacy to this
bill anyone who watches um the news
local local news manchester has been hit
in some high profile uh smash and grab
types of things
realizes that that the longer we allow
this to go on the longer the bad actors
are able to become sophisticated with us
and a interim study will just delay
something that retail and consumers are
crying for and if we're not here for
both of those parties retail and
consumers both um then who are we here
for so i think it's time that we we
address this um
rather than to put it on the table for
interim study thank you
so representative weston i i do want to
say thank you for sending that along um
and been telling me to make sure i read
the last sentence which i might not have
uh and which has said the federal
legislation is still live
it's still on a bill
it's stalled everything's stalled
so but in terms of normally this
committee if there
if things that are still going on in the
uh in washington we usually wait until
the dust settle i.e when it came to
extern you know um extra uh external
review not really external but uh um
balanced billing uh that you know why
why wouldn't it make sense to wait until
after the federal government has acted
and then take take an action i think
there's a lot of i think there are a lot
of cases where we don't do that
where we try to push things through in
spite of the fact that it should be a
federal
uh law and a lot of times we really opt
for a state solution instead
i think that happens all the time i'm
sure it does but this is this one is
clearly the state is really in inept all
it can do is ask
amazon to go do its homework it really
has no authority it doesn't it really
can't force them to do anything it can't
shut them down it can't force them to do
something differently there are states
that are enacting this now we're not
alone on this this is happening across
the country
and i think it also sends a message we
do influence what the marketplace does
we do it oh i mean i i know from other
uh experiences like the pfas thing
are the motions that were taking place
in vermont affected the entire industry
for ski wax so i we can we can make a
difference and i think this is an
opportunity yeah i think it gives them
false impression that that there there's
somebody out there really doing
something
representative
bartlett
thank you mr chair um with all due
respect i do see a difference between
your example regarding balanced billing
which is in the courts
um different than what legislation that
is being worked on no it's big pieces of
the balance bill
section that is in courts and that was
why we put off any further movement on
that one okay
uh representative johnson
nope
don't excuse me
i'm
it's my flaming red hair yeah
you look you look so much light today
oh well
i agree with the idea
that allowing criminals to
get away with their crimes we want to
bust them knowing no one is trying to
enable or
in any other way try to make it easy for
them to get away with their crimes we
certainly want them arrested we want
them punished
one of my concerns about the bill as it
is written
is that it is targeting
a very select few retail outlets
and ignoring
what would be much easier
outlets for the sale of stolen property
it's not to say that amazon doesn't have
stolen goods it's not to say amazon or
any other
of these large retail don't have
uh
counterfeits or anything like that
but the problem is is is that
knowing what the requirements are to be
a third-party seller on those platforms
and not having those same requirements
at other outlets such as an ebay or a
craigslist or things like that this bill
totally ignores those smaller outlets
and so i i i think that if we're going
to do something let's make sure that we
are actually
targeting
where we we need to be looking where we
actually need to be looking i think
amazon is an easy scapegoat because
they're so large and if we need to
address them yes well let's do that but
i think we're ignoring so many other
outlets to be able to sell those the
smash and grab
looted looted goods so i i think an
interim study would would allow us to
better tailor the bill to where we
actually need to focus our attention
representing manhattan thank you mr
chair uh just a couple of follow-up
points
we're talking here about the potential
for
counterfeit drugs and medications too so
if we if we are looking at stalling
something that's important for the
consumer as well as for the retailer
whose
inventory is being stolen in a smash and
grab and granted it is the big guys the
big guys are the ones that are most
responsible i'd also i really would like
just to point out that there's a
contingency at the end at the end of the
bill which has to do with federal
legislation
and uh it says
there's similar federal legislation
requiring online marketplaces to verify
and disclose certain information if it
has become law prior to january 1 2023
section one of the sex shall not take
effect so we are kind of covering our
bases all the way around we are saying
that new hampshire uh supports consumers
supports retailers and supports the idea
that um bad actors benefit from
anonymity and so if we take away their
anonymity then we take away that that
veil of crime from them as i i indicated
in a little
to do with our with my seat made here
when i attempted to take her phone um i
i have my name plate here i have my
badge here if i'm going to be a bad
actor i'm not going to do it unless i'm
anonymous and so i really think that it
is time for us to step up on behalf of
of of these people and we're not hurting
amazon we're not hurting those big
people or just asking them to be
accountable for the same thing that a
brick and mortar store is accountable
for so um with that said i just would
like to point out again there is a
contingency here and so uh there is a
chance for us to do something
before the remainder of the states which
are multiples 24 plus states or at least
considering it uh before the multiples
uh do it and we'll be part of that
federal action if it happens
that's interesting you brought in brick
and mortar
this doesn't include brick and mortar so
therefore a brick and mortar person
could have bought a trailer load of
illegal or stolen products and sell it
at half price and nobody would know the
difference but we have the information
on those people so once we detect that
something is still they stole it they
did rick and we don't have any
requirements on a brick and mortar to
tell us who their distributor or where
the how they get their product but
they're culpable the brick and mortar
store the seller is couple so i go back
to
to the brick and mortar walmart and say
this is a counterfeit drug this is a the
um the serial number is shaved off the
bottom of this bicycle frame uh they are
culpable they are accountable the ag can
then step in and take a look at that
because we know who they are we know
their phone number we know whatever we
know contact information
and so we should at least know that
about our online retailers as well uh
resellers i should say
i guess not resellers
thank you
yeah i just would like to remind the
committee members that we had a police
chief um testifying
uh regarding smash and grabs and in
regards to this bill and he was in full
support of this bill thank you
yeah
okay you know i i but
to me smash and grab implies you did not
take the packaging with it and this bill
legislation specifically says
it has to be in its original
packaging
so in most of smash and grabs i have
when i see when someone steal a rolex
they're not looking in the cabinet for
the the box the rolex came in
yes representative bartlett but we
certainly have um the examples right in
manchester of the atvs the golf carts
they were all they were stolen
in the truckload in their original
crates
and they were new
in their original package packaging i
guess i missed that one i just saw the
guy with the 80 you sold 80 100 billion
industry
okay
is there any more discussion on the
motion
representative grayson thank you thank
you this time
i no longer have red hair
nothing in this bill requires any proof
of
ownership
or
right to sell
a product
how do we know how does amazon know
that johnny bob has the right to sell
the goods there's nothing to say that
that 10 000 units of maybelline mascara
he didn't pilfer from revco or whatever
you know he there's nothing to show
that he has the right to sell it
and so this bill does not deal with that
so this master grade is not going to do
anything with whether knowing it's
stolen goods or not okay i think we're
we're all set
all right
uh the motion is in in uh interim study
clerk may call the role representative
yes representative osborne
clerk votes yes representative sanborn
representative hamm
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert no
representative and houghton
representative fargo no
representative weston no
representative bellew no
representative burroughs nope
representative mcaleer no
chairman hunt
yes
ten to nine
okay
uh will there be a minority report well
representative uh van houden will be
doing it
already written
even better
and up to pass
okay last one
uh
okay uh
oh we have 3 40. i'm sorry where am i
okay 340. uh relative to consumer
shipment of alcohol
and representative below second by
representative patusik moves in
expedient to legislate
any discussion on the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
when he's ready
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
you left the room oh
clerk votes yes
representative
sanborn
representative ham
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
no
representative abel
representative herbert
representative van houten
no
representative fargo
representative weston no
representative bill you no
representative burroughs no
representative mclear no
and chairman hunts
um
i i
yes
so i okay yes you vote yes yeah yeah
okay so i guess
nine to nine because osborne was out of
the room
so what was your strategy what's your
game plan here
this was on the amendment right this was
no this is interim study i mean it's
gonna be you know he uh we were itling
340. no amendment we were just killing
the bill
why would you guys flip your vote on
that you know what
and i can understand why we're confused
considering what happened in the
subcommittee this is this was our
confusion
okay
so the motion is passed but you you will
we're emotional
so we will move to reconsider the action
we just took yes okay uh
all those in favor of reconsideration
please raise your hand
okay
everybody in the rooms raise their hand
all those opposed oh that's so unanimous
okay so we will take the motion up again
don't we didn't it was a you didn't have
you don't have to it's a it's a
meaningless moment
okay
so
you know
sorry
okay the motion is
representing below
moves
inexpedient to legislate
seconded
by
uh
seconded by
uh representative abel
is the motion clear
thank you yes
okay the clerk will call the role on
inexpedient allegedly all right let's
try this again
representative patousik yes
representative osborne
representative ammon votes yes
representative sanborn
representative hamm
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
this time yes
representative herbert
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative bell you yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelroy yes
the chairman hunt
yes
19-0
okay all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
so deja vu
senate bill 319 relative vaccine status
and wellness and incentives uh
representative patusek and represented
by representative bartlett moves
we reconsider our action
it's non-debatable motion
all those in favor wait a minute i um
i'm not going to second that one you
said to me earlier that you agreed that
we should just do reconsideration you
got that one past me i'm sorry
okay have somebody else second i know
i'm gonna lose but
okay
represents uh sanborn
no
so who's uh reconsideration on our
action where we took and no she yes
excuse me i'm representing yeah i'm fine
with it going with no recommendation to
okay all right
all right so the pending motion is to
reconsider our action where we fail to
get a vote
any discussion on the motion of
reconsideration
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one two three
eight nine ten
eleven
okay for reconsideration
okay those opposed
one two three four five
eight
okay
motion carries
all right the pending motion uh again is
uh
senate bill three nineteen i got my
answers here okay so representative
greeson seconded by representative terry
moves um inexpedient to legislate
any discussion on the motion
reminiscent of abel
okay remember it's in bartlett
thanks um
i have to vote against this motion i
feel this is just an enabling bill this
doesn't say anybody has to do anything
that if a carrier wants to make an
incentive an employer wants to offer an
incentive
for a vaccination
for this vaccination
then i think they should be able to i
don't think we should be telling them
they can't
representative greeson
thank you mr chair uh what this bill
also does not do
is
prevent anyone from taking action
against anyone who might refuse said
incentive
for whatever their reasons i don't want
it
and so
uh you can enable them to you not only
enable them to offer the incentive but
you also enable them to punish anyone
who doesn't take the incentive so that's
why i believe it should be itl
representing van halen i simply see
nothing that would punish anybody
incentives are just there if you wish to
have them um
as we said enabled and if if i wish to
take it fine if not i don't see that i'm
going to be punished i i think that
we're reading something else into the
bill there uh i also think that um
is we run our world on incentives how
many of us incentivize our kids to do
their homework by taking away iphones or
ipads or whatever the case might be it's
simply a way of indicating what you feel
is a a just way of doing things and in
this case the insurance carrier is
potentially saving itself hundreds of
thousands of dollars with people who for
whom the vaccine will keep them out of
hospitals and keep them healthier and
safer and so i think those are
considerations that we have to look at
as we vote thank you representative
it would seem to me that a health
carrier
is not going to offer an incentive
unless they've basically uh created some
sort of an algorithm algorithm
whatever
algorithm that that this
the cost of the incentive will be far
outweighed by the savings of uh of this
so i think this is a a whole public
health thing i think i think to to
disincentivize people
um is wrong and i think that's what
you're you're trying to do this should
incentivize people to to do what uh
may be very helpful and and to to
prevent them somebody from taking a
vaccine i i also see how this this whole
anti-vax thing could could move over to
polio vaccine and some other vaccines
which would be extremely dangerous
extremely uh harmful to uh
to public health and everybody's else
this is a good bill and it should pass
you know representative mclare you
absolutely got it right no insurance
company could offer this
unless they can document that this is
actually
a
will have the benefit that save the
hundred thousands of dollars that you
claim
because that's the law they can do it
already
if they can come up with that algorithm
today
and figure out that giving away some
incentive and no taking away someone's
phone is not that somebody could get
could get ice cream
that yeah that absolutely was perfect
this bill is totally unnecessary
and frankly it set the wrong president
because it really should go and say you
know that you know reaffirm what
everybody already knows that if
insurance company can document and make
it make a case i mean i call it with the
guy with the green shades but you know
the algorithm is a good word too so but
that yeah you're absolutely right
okay representative amen
yeah i just wanted to comment it's
interesting that the insurance
corporation is the parent in the uh in
the in the child parent analogy so i
just thought that was interesting
okay
uh
the question clear the clerk will call
the rule on inexpedient to legislate
representative patusek
representative osborne
representative amman votes yes
representative sanborn
representative ham
representative de
palma representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
no
representative abel no
representative herbert
representative in houghton no
representative fargo no
representative weston no
representative bill you
no
representative burroughs no
representative mcaleer no
chairman hunt yes
11 to eight okay i assume we'll have a
minority report yes i'll do the minority
report
okay
um before i recess exec session i now
have the official copy
of the amendment for senate bill 202
and uh i'll pass that around and so we
will correct the files or did
you you just sent him out
we'll correct the file so for your
records the amendment will be
1858 on senate bill 202 and anybody like
a copy of it can come up here and get it
so you can cross this off yeah exactly
what is it again 202 18 1858.
okay
otherwise
let's all head over to tandy's and have
a committee luncheon
yes and uh before before we leave
and we'll say goodbye to tyler
nightmares
you